heute backe ich mal Fabians absolutes
Lieblingsessen nach Tiefkühlpizza hey
Sebastian Mittagessen
aber ist die auch gesund ich habe da so
meine Zweifel
nein aber warte der ist ohne Ende Zucker
drin in dem Blitzen da doch ich treffe
ZDF besser Esser Sebastian lege er nimmt
Lebensmittel auseinander guckt was drin
ist und baut sie wieder zusammen
[Musik]
durch das gibt's ausschließlich damit zu
Hause nicht nur zwischendurch
tatsächlich
das ist wirklich mein allergrößtes
Problem weil es so gerne ist nee weil
ihr Kinder eigentlich nicht werden
und da habe ich eine extreme Abneigung
geben also da werde ich auch richtig
aggressiv was soll ich sagen
willst ich habe jetzt extra auch hier
Fabian und zwar egal Kumpel von mir er
ist der zieht sich sowas dann in der
Woche vorbei ich habe seine
Lieblingspizza heute mitgebracht das ist
die größte hier die Steinofen Pizza
Spezial und die ist ja jetzt guck mal
Käse Salami weißt du eigentlich das
gerade bei so Wurstwaren ja
ich war klar Schweinefleisch Leuchte an
Salz solltet ihr auch weinen ja dritte
Zutat Dextrose Zuckerstoff warum Zucker
hat kein MD umso mehr Zucker umso länger
haltbar Zucker ist der
Konservierungsstoff Nummer 1
überall weißt du warum solche Produkte
so richtig gut laufen und ein absoluter
profitmaker sind
Schinken Salami Tomatensoße überall
Zucker drin echt deprimieren aber warum
ist das eigentlich so
zucker ist ein sehr sehr lukratives
Geschäft
billig aber noch was ja raffinierter
Zucker aus Deutschland ist extrem
nachhaltig der Zucker wird der hier
gewonnen ausruhen und ich sag mal es
wird ja so gerne mit alternativen
gearbeitet wie
kokosblütenzucker horrorzucker aus allen
jetzt den zuckeralterative gemacht nur
die Rohstoffe wachsen ja gar nicht
Zucker ist nicht schlecht ist wirklich
viel viel weniger
[Musik]
und jetzt wagen wir das Unmögliche wir
backen eine Pizza mit und eine ohne
Zuckerzusatz
das hast du gemacht
ich wollte die Dinger hochwerfen wie die
Italien
[Musik]
ich finde der Unterschied ist minimal
oder klar genau vom Geschmack kann man
sich Zucker komplett sparen richtig und
jetzt mal interessant aber hier ist das
wichtig das Produkt auch die
Fließeigenschaft Zucker ist auch eine
Stabilisator Zucker wie du ihn siehst ja
guck mal
richtig hart er gibt mir auch ein
gewisses Gerüst an Stabilität gibt es
denn eigentlich gesunde Alternativen
Zucker wo man sagt so nimm besser das
das ist gesund und auch süß bleibt süß
Kohlenhydrate
auch Honig ist dann ist alles das ist
eine wird also ich sag mal
Honig fruchtzucker wird langsamer
verstoffwechselt Insulin knallt nicht
gleich nach oben ne das ist ja einzige
Vorteil aber energetisch ist beides das
gleiche weißt du eigentlich habe eine
Statistik ja viel Tiefkühlpizzen in
Deutschland pro Jahr verspeist werden
die Zahl habe ich nicht im Kopf eine
Milliarde
na wer hat hier den Pizzahut auf
ich habe das wirklich noch nie gemacht
[Musik]
jetzt lass mich doch mal machen ich muss
mich doch erstmal da rein finden erstmal
richtig Mehlen ja und auch hier den
Lümmel auch mal richtig einreiben
[Musik]
bei dem mir Sebastian durfte
Sebastian wie lange noch wie lange
dauert noch wie lange noch Vernetzung
wird auf alle Fälle bestraft oder
ich finde ohne Scheiß optisch schon mal
absolut ähnlich ich nehme so ein schönes
Stück ja das ist erstmal die Variante
mit Zucker
also ich muss sagen Kompliment schmeckt
genauso Last in der Tiefkühlpizza oder
jetzt mal die ohne
man schmeckt schon Unterschied voll ich
hätte nicht gedacht wie viel Zucker dann
doch ausmacht im Geschmack ich finde
hier die schmeckt richtig süß ja genau
aber das fällt einem jetzt auch erst auf
finde ich im Direktvergleich wie viel
wie viel das dann doch ausmachen und es
schmeckt leider auch mit Zucker es
schmeckt besser oder scheiße ich hätte
gerne das Gegenteil überhaupt ich bin
überrascht wie süß eine Pizza ist weil
wenn du wenn du die ohne Zucker ist wird
dir das erst bewusst total und es ist
echt krass und ich würde jetzt mal
gucken ich gehe jetzt mal raus wir sind
hier in Düsseldorf ja mal sehen ob die
Leute das auch so sehen wie wir genau
viel Spaß danke dir und wenn du Hilfe
brauchst sag bescheid ne ne tschüss
kannst du mir die Tür aufmachen ist
nämlich abgeschlossen
ich habe Pizza und sonst kein Interesse
also ich sage Ihnen mal das erste ist
eine Pizza wie sie so mit mir üblichen
Zuckeranteil also ordentlich Zucker drin
wie man sie kriegt im Supermarkt und die
zweite Pizza ist komplett ohne
Zuckerzusatz gebacken schwer also sie
finden den Unterschied gar nicht so groß
ohne Zucker geht auch für sie genauso
lecker ja okay sie müssen beide
Varianten probieren die und die warum ja
das werden sie dann müssen dann
entscheiden welche besser schmecken also
das ist Version
habe ich selber gebacken übrigens
ja die ist schon mal lecker okay dann
müssen sie jetzt auch noch die zweite
Version ja aber dann ist der Test der
völlig unbrauchbar haben
aber im Nachgang ohne Zucker
ein wenig besser echt ohne Zucker
schmeckt besser sogar ich habe das
gebacken mit Sebastian lege Pizza aus
Napoli Oma Damen also wie ist das Napoli
was würden Sie sagen welche schmeckt
besser die erste die zweite die zweite
die zweite schmeckt besser das war die
ohne Zuckerzusatz die schmeckt ihnen
besser sogar welche schmeckt besser wie
hast du die zweite leider die erste
ja die mit Zucker finde ich auch geiler
leider warum der nicht die andere das
wäre doch als Fazit für diesen Beitrag
viel besser gewesen
genau
was hältst du denn davon dass jetzt
Werbung eingeschränkt werden soll von
Lebensmitteln
ich habe so hunger ich habe seit Tagen
nichts gegessen warum du wolltest doch
nur auf Produkte mit Zuckerzusatz
verzichten ja das geht ja nicht ist ja
überall Zucker drin sogar ein Schokolade
halt durch du kannst jetzt so Ablenkung
weitere Videos von uns angucken hier
oder auch in Marmelade das auch Zucker
drin ich breche ab